if I don't have headphones on I'm not
working and if I'm going to wear
headphones all day I want the best
headphones in the world and those are
the hi-fi man hd6 so what's good about
these is first of all well first of all
they're open they're open backed so if
you play music the entire world will
hear a tinny version of your music
pretty loudly so if you are if you're
working in an office with other people
you can't wear open headphones please
don't please don't be that person and
that includes everything from great oh
sorry great Oh people but if you're
working in an office alone you can do
open and boy the sound quality is
amazing what do you listen to I'm sorry
I listen to fish mostly fish lots of
fish I have 34 days worth of fish this
is most of their albums and every live
show they've played since 2009 what I
like about them is that they are pretty
consistent the music just I like the
music to begin with and they release
every every concert they do and they
tour a lot every concert they do they
release it on their website and you can
buy it for like 10 bucks so that's where
all this came from and so it's like
getting a new album from the band you
like like 10 times a year or more it's
it's great so they so then I can well
I'm working I can put one of these shows
on I don't I don't do shuffle I just
play straight through I can put one of
these shows on and then I don't have to
think about my music for the next 36
days tell me about your keyboard this is
the Microsoft sculpt ergonomic desktop
keyboard Microsoft yeah the Microsoft
makes the best organ on keyboards they
have for years if not ever they really
you know if you want the kind of split
design basically in my first few years
of working sorry but the dirtiness I'd
in my first few years of working
professionally as a programmer my Sarah
develops wrist soreness and I was afraid
of RSI issues and so I made a couple of
minor changes biggest one was I switched
to a split keyboard and I haven't that
was 10 years ago and I haven't have any
problem since just normal yeah yeah it
rest oh no you can't I mean that's kind
of subtle my elbow on this sometimes
that's why it's all crunched up I'll
often sit like this I can if I'm
thinking about a problem or if I'm
browsing something online it's nice and
comfortable there it's kind of spongy
bullet-time yeah it's like a little like
you know it's it's you know it's a fake
leather pad you know it's fine
and you mouse there you got normal
normal Mouse yeah the Apple Magic Mouse
nothing special
I like the inertial scrolling on it yeah
and a piece of gold or something there
that's it's on yeah it's this crappy
Teflon pad that just it makes it glide
really easily as a dolt it's just a
sheet of Teflon
so it's yeah I don't know it's I order
from some crazy internet supplier for
like 10 bucks at some point in the past
look pops is up high hubs temporarily oh
hey goes good boy so you what evil
computer you running here this is the 5k
iMac from last year it's the one-year
old model and I love it it's the best
computer I've ever owned by far
absolutely love it it's fast the screen
is gorgeous
it's huge everything I want I'm editing
podcasts I'll have like Adobe Audition
running or logic than what I'm doing
probably logic actually and then most of
the time if I'm doing overcast work then
I'll have Xcode running and then this is
the iOS simulator running here and so
when you're making iOS apps Apple gives
you this little simulated window here so
you can actually run the whole app right
here in a window and it's it's just like
just like having a little iPhone on your
computer so it's great so over here is
all the source code and there's this
giant list of all the all the files this
isn't even all of them it's overcast as
a lot of files and a lot of lines of
code because this is one file over here
you can see how long it is and this is
granted a pretty important one a pretty
big one but what does that want to do
this is the main streaming player this
is how the streaming player works of
like you know getting the data from the
source and putting it through the
decoder and decoding mp3s into sound
decoding you know m4a etc and then being
able to stream it without having the
whole file downloaded so that's all
that's this is part of that this isn't
even all that is part of that they're
really there any two things you need to
make a cool app you just need those two
things that's it really basically I mean
you can you can go into you know
graphical programs to make the assets
for it to make the icons and so it's
stuff like that but most of the work is
right here it's Xcode and a simulator
that's most of the work and
there was things like service and let's
sort of stuff what do you need for that
it depends I mean you need like a
terminal window basically you need like
terminals - I always have terminals
running you know terminals running here
and you know monitoring your stuff but
most apps don't even need servers
anymore you know for the most part
people don't really use most apps except
for like you know big web services those
will use servers of course but I don't
think a lot of people use servers
anymore this is basically audio stuff so
this is a headphone amp this is it's by
a company called yes and on there
it's well this is their logo it's SCH
iit okay right but it is pronounced
so this is my headphone amp and
this is the DAC I'm still not entirely
sure I believe in audiophile DAX
but I got one anyway just in case and
then over on this side I have my
podcasting setup so I have my podcasting
microphone the Noi Minh kms 105 a
word yes use the USB filter I have a
whining dog and this is my my microphone
interface the USB pre - on top of a Mac
Mini home server and a blu-ray reader
for some reason I bought the blu-ray
reader thinking about be ripping all my
movies and converted them so I could
watch them you know on an ass and watch
on my Apple TV and in practice I have
not done that because it's a pain in the
butt I am NOT a hard worker I do a lot
but I don't have I don't have a lot of
consistency in my hours I don't have a
ton of discipline like when when or
where I do things I just kind of do
things whenever I can and whenever I'm
up to it and I have to kind of tackle
problems with that in mind so like I
won't tackle a problem that requires
constant input from me or you know tons
of dedicated scheduling or tons of other
people to be involved
I don't hire other people I don't have
any employees because I would be a
terrible manager of other employees and
I would probably do less work than them
and that would be weird
I generally just do what I can with my
one slacker self are you a good model in
should people think that's the way to do
or you
you're terrible role model all I've done
I mean I did terribly in school and
everything like all I've done is found a
way that I can take my slacker self and
earn a living I have no idea it will
work for other people and that's on a
screen called nitpicky details every
time I do things like this I think it's
a risk and I think maybe it'll turn off
some people and every time I work but no
one really notices my job I look back on
it kind of the way I look back on
college it's like it's something